alfred monthieux bonjour bonjour alors
vous tenter cette année un quatrième
mandat et demie 1 puisque vous êtes
maire du robert depuis 1997 et vous êtes
même aux affaires municipales pour ainsi
dire au conseil municipal depuis 25 ans
maintenant
alors pourquoi vous tenter ce quatrième
mandat et demi comme je les dis je la
vole la population nous avons nous
sommes engagés à transformer lober un
doublé 89
puisque c'est depuis qu'il a commencé un
travail conséquent et depuis quelques
années au dessus mais j'ai dû acheter un
fossé considérable pour la ville nous
permettre de faire nos projets que ça
fasse yens veut pas faire le bruit
donc c'est pourquoi la population va
solliciter encore mes camarades
également sollicités ça veut dire qu a
pas de relève dans votre groupe dans
votre mouvement politique
est-ce que vous préparez vous même la
relève alfred mongy et à la ola puisque
ce mandat c'est un manager de transition
le mandat qui vient là celui là 2020
2026 vous permettre aux jeunes ou aux
autres de le faire donc vous annoncer
que quoi qu'il arrive si vous êtes réélu
ce sera votre dernière mandat de maire
oui c'est ça la demeure puisque j'ai des
jeunes et à des moins jeunes également
puisqu'il ya l'expérience de voyage et
alors qu'est ce que vous retenez de fort
sur les six dernières années la ce
dernier mandat la key qui s'achève
qu'est ce que vous avez fait de fort
qu'est ce que voulait mettre en avant la
maladie en 2004
de muguet des malades ou difficile
puisque avec la réduction de la dgf nous
avions connu beaucoup de difficultés
mais avec les services de la mairie et
mes collègues élus nous avions travaillé
vous ne parlez de rouge ce qui nous a
permis de faire des écoles exemple aider
également à 608 donc au point de vue
éducation nous avons peur nous avons pu
réaliser et que le mano césaire l'école
de lots de lépine et nous avons l'école
de ponte s'était fait dérober cap
d'aillois que céder sous mandat durera
donc il ya les écoles le foncier c'est
quelque chose de fondamental boulot donc
si elle a devancé albert comme le même
nom et deux d'argent et le développement
économique est ce que ça donne
notamment bon il ya ces cas-là ce maire
robert mais peut-être créer d'autres
choses
nous avons connu d'autres choses puisque
en matière de développement économique
nous avons plusieurs pôles économiques
il y avait des lieux des dégâts dit
qu'ils sont devenus des quartiers
entiers regardiez le gâchette
c'est un champ de cannes dans les années
passées de nous avons pu avec un apport
des entreprises qui sont venus souhaiter
voir avec les terrains que nous leur
avons vendu également
ils se sont installés vous quel est
l'emploi et fonctionnels de l'entreprise
à la manière puisque se gardent de
l'avion peuvent crier mais ceux qui
n'ont pas d'argent ils attendent
énormément pour avoir pire puisque la
pôle économique des cachettes et à
pratiquer noir beaucoup d'entre eux
puisqu'ils se sont installés à gâchette
et c'est là que des ados 10 des emplois
nous avons pu nous avons un pôle
économique hamas a également sur la
route nationale et à l'automobile et le
bois est un autre qui s'installe à gap
fini et il ya des habitations qui se
fond derrière et bio goobye la face du
stade
nous avons un pôle économique et créer
pour bt rebelles hockey alors il ya eu
aussi à vos adieux bien la seule où nous
avions installé actuellement il ya 1,7
médicale
c'est cela la semaine une boulanger
patrice y est bien deux installations
puisque la semaine ça augmenter
énormément
alors voilà donc on va maintenant se
projeter sur le prochain mandat
si si si vous passez un mois de masse si
vous êtes réélu alors deux ou trois
projets prioritaires fort rapidement
parce que je voudrais qu'on parle aussi
qu'on dise quelques mots sur cap nord à
la fin alors je me suis engagé devant le
peuple debout mais pour servir le peuple
et elle nous avons nous devons continuer
à faire développer l'économie hamas à
damas
il ya deux acteurs de terrain le prévu
ou les oubliés nous avons demandé des
autorisations
il ya ceux qui nous avaient demandé par
le passé mais il n'avait pas les moyens
financiers de sevojno bête et réalisez
vous avez un site médical qui a commencé
à la et un massage d'égarement et
d'autre est possible d'économiser entre
des périodes mais le danger
le musée de la mer je crois ou quelque
chose comme ça qui vous tient alors nous
arriver soutien municipal qui s'est un
peu difficile
lâchez vous voulez continuer je voulais
réaliser quand nous avions trouvé le
terrain c'est cap blanc qui a acheté
quatre hectares bout face au volant et
ben justement alors vous voulez rester
présidente cap nord pour pouvoir
réaliser ce projet est-ce que vous avez
cette ambition là de ne pas plonger non
la peine de quatre mois pour être
président de blizzard
il faut d'abord et si vous aimez
si vous êtes plus particulièrement la
pole et la population du mono d'être
mère je serai candidat pour la
présidence de nous avions comme tout
d'abord de 98 j'ai parlé de la
facturation de la facture des tricheurs
morning et deuxièmement qu'il fallait
avoir un prix unique de l'eau etc ça
comme ça vous arrive à faire pour les 18
communes et compris le verbe et et
mumbai et qui avait depuis les habitants
des habitants est gay le verbe et ceux
qui habitent loin et a subi un examen
municipal n'a jamais n'a jamais ne sais
pas d'où aperçoit le même la même somme
celui du abp elle est beaucoup plus cher
donc à partir du mois d'avril leur
impunité se libère et louis élevé après
merci alfred monthieux d'avoir répondu à
nos questions dans cette émission
réalisée par paul eric tout ça